[Music]
In Australia, forestry is a major
industry and we occupy about 125 million
hectares all up and 16% of our Our land
mass area in Australia is forest or
plantation. Most states of Australia
have a major forestry hub situated
within them. At Green Triangle Forest
Products, we manage about 25,000
hectares of pine plantations in the
Green Triangle region of Australia. The
Green Triangle region is in the
southeastern part of South Australia and
the southwestern part of Victoria. Now,
in forestry, we're not unlike any other
farmer you that may farm cows or may
farm sheep. Here, we farm trees. And
when those trees grow to maturity, we
harvest them. We cut them and process
them into logs or chips. And uh and
that's our commodity. What's different
about us though is that we manage our
trees over a much longer term than a
farmer would usually manage a cow or a
sheep. Some of our rotations last for 35
or even 40 years. Basic cycle in
plantation forestry is site preparation,
planting, weed control, forest
management, and then harvesting.
We in pine will thin our trees two to
three times before we clear for them
when they're 35 to 40 years of age. It's
actually a very high technology process
where we have equipment mainly imported
from Europe and that will cut down a
tree that may take 40 years to grow in
less than a minute and process it. And
this is what we call a mechanical
harvester. Not every mill produces the
same product. They will mill a very
specific kind of log and they will
produce a very specific kind of product.
Generally the higher value products like
our saw log is processed domestically.
Products that we don't process locally
we export overseas. So things like uh
pulp, wood chips and other small low
value logs we will export to other
countries that have the processing
facilities there to manufacture other
products. Some companies in forestry are
so large that they have processing
facilities the world over and that's
good for them because what they can do
is they can share their inputs.
Kimberly Clark is a global company that
produces health and hygiene products um
such as toilet paper uh facial tissue,
kitchen towel, um diapers. Um here in
Australia we produce tissue and this
mill produces all of the tissue for
Australia and New Zealand. The tissue
that we produce here uses a range of
fibers. And we import pulp from New
Zealand and we import pulp from South
America and we import pulp from North
America. And the the different fiber
types provide different characteristics
in the products that we produce. It
comes in bales which you'll see and
comes in on a truck and then they go
into what we call a hydropula where the
pulp is mixed up with water and then
from the hydropula it goes to a tissue
machine where it's made into tissue and
rolled up and folded into the products
that you you'll see around us. Well, out
of this mill we produce around 80,000
tons of tissue a year. That equates to
around 26 B trucks of product leave here
every day. We look to recover and
recycle anything that is a waste from
this mill. Uh currently we've been
successful in recycling 96% of our waste
from this mill so that it doesn't go
into landfill. So only 4% of our waste
from the mill goes to landfill. We have
a lot of technology on the mill which
requires a broad base of skills to
operate it. We have mechanical
engineers, we have electrical engineers,
we have a lot of traded people, we have
automated guided vehicles behind us,
which until recently that job would have
been done by someone on a fork truck.
But we also have accountants and we have
various other people in staff roles and
highly trained and highly skilled
operators that operate the plant 24
hours a day. So there's an amazing range
of skills and job roles in this mill for
it to operate. It's really hard to uh
imagine when you look around here and
you see all the plastic and you see all
the products and the people around us to
know that none of this would have
happened without a Great.
[Music]
Thank